[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and wow what an
eye it was out in san diego as per usual
marvel completely blew the roof off in
hall h and they announced not only their
phase 5 panel but also some of phase 6
2. it was an amazing event packed with
major announcements great trailers and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down if you've been
following the channel live then you'll
know i posted my black panther wakanda
forever trailer breakdown at 4 30 a.m i
went to bed at five one of my sons woke
me about half five so shout out harry
spoilers for letting me get an hour's
sleep because of that i'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also your
subscription we're not getting much
sleep out here so all the love is
appreciated without the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so kevin foggy basically came out
and everyone was like what about phase
four and he did a wonder said no more
phase 4 what phase 4
you can tell i've not had much sleep
anyway from the off he said that phase 4
was at an end and that things would
culminate with black panther wakunda
forever as mentioned we've done a full
breakdown on that trailer and it's
definitely one of my most anticipated
movies just the entire feel to it was
really somber and emotional and they
actually closed out the entire thing by
giving us that new look they sort of did
things in a weird order and actually
announced all of phase five first and
then moved into phase six now the first
movie they put into phase five is
ant-man and the wasp quantomania they
also dropped a poster for that yesterday
and jonathan mages came out on stage and
basically talked about doing some
conquering
[Applause]
this is obviously building off the back
of loki and it's going to set up a lot
of things that we'll talk about later on
in the video now the poster also gave us
our first sucker cassie lang in the suit
and she's in purple so i'm guessing that
she's gonna be going by stinger in the
comic she also went by statue but this
was eventually changed to stinger and
with it being purple i'm guessing that
that's what they're doing here now they
also announced that modok will be one of
the villains from what i can gather he's
being played by corey stoll who
portrayed darren cross aka yellowjacket
in the first ant-man movie he of course
disappeared into the quantum realm and
apparently kang will have recruited him
to be part of his forces it's also
important to bear in mind that just like
how we had the infinity saga this will
be known as the multiverse saga not
everything is going to connect directly
into that but there are some key titles
here that definitely build towards the
idea of secret wars now going from that
you might think secret invasion ties
into it but it doesn't really outside of
the word secret in the comics this was
basically about a skrull invasion in
which several of them replaced heroes
using their shape-shifting abilities
from what i've heard on my sources the
tomato ones they said that it's it's
sort of very political along the lines
of the winter soldier and though it's
not as bombastic as the comics which
spiraled into all that war there's still
a lot of things going on and there will
be some major twists calling it right
now this guy is a scroll i'm telling you
he's a scroll serial was right stop we
don't that's all
next is going to be guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. there are some looks at
this on twitter lots of clips were shown
apparently there was a trailer that was
very emotional
you might be able to find it if you look
i'm not putting it in this video because
of copyright reasons but yeah there was
a lot of big things happening with it
james gunn came on stage along with the
rest of the cast and they basically
hammered home the idea that this is the
end of the guardians however gunn wanted
to make it clear that the end doesn't
mean that the guardians will be dead and
instead you know they're going to kind
of pace things out a bit they also
confirm that the high evolutionary will
be the villain of the piece and that
we'll also discover the origins of
rocket there was a baby raccoon shown at
one point and sadly rocket apparently he
wasn't in that much of the trailer so
i'm hoping hoping the guy's still going
we also have a big description of the
footage and apparently the guardians get
captured by the ravages who are now
being led by gamora peter quill is
called all the way off guard and he
reflects on their time together
according to the leaky says you were
everything to me i thought you were gone
but you're here and i miss you gamora
tells him that person was not here and
we also get our first look at adam
warlock now right after this we're going
to have echo which is building on the
events of hawkeye it's also going to
feature charlie cox's daredevil and
vincent d'onofrio is the kingpin charlie
cox is two gonna show up in she-hulk and
we're gonna look at him in the trailer
which i'll put on screen right now for
you you don't have to go looking for
that one but from here we get loki
season 2 which is currently being filmed
obviously this is going to be massively
built around the multiverse 2. judging
by that cliffhanger it's going to
feature kangalot and yeah i'm guessing
it'll tie into the events of ant-man and
the wasp quantomania and
sort of segue off into that my guess as
well with the ant-man movie is that it's
going to end in a big l and basically
have kang set up as the major threat of
this overarching multiverse saga from
here we go to the marvels which yeah
tying directly into the end of miss
marvel and apparently this is actually
gonna open with a musical for about the
first hour carol's meant to take the
characters to a planner where everyone
sings instead of talking and i am quite
interested to see how that plays out
next in november is blade which is
building off the back of the eternals
very little is known about this movie i
was kind of hoping for some casting
announcements but sadly we didn't get
much more information beyond what we
were told at the last comic-con up next
is iron heart a disney plus show that
will center around riri williams who
will be introduced in black panther
wakanda forever after that is agatha
coven of chaos and then daredevil born
again this is going to be 18 episodes
long by far the longest disney plus show
ever and i'm hoping that it gets at
least a tbma we did get the writing for
marvel zombies announced the other day
and that's going to be tv ma2 so hoping
that's the case here a born again of
course has a lot of meanings to it as
it's the same title as the seminal frank
miller book i am very very curious to
see how they work this in as i'm sure
many of you know season three of
daredevil was actually also based on
this as well so whether they're gonna be
taking aspects of that or just doing
their own version in the mcu we don't
know but yeah the title it brings a lot
with it up next is captain america new
world order
now this will be sam wilson's first
feature film debut as cab and the title
itself also carries a lot with it though
it's not spelled out i kind of feel like
this might be based on secret empire and
i have a crazy theory about what could
be going on now if you haven't read that
book then the big thing to take from it
is that captain america steve rogers is
actually a hydra agent i'd absolutely
love it in this film if a young captain
america turned up and then he was
revealed to be the villain can you
imagine that chris evans shows up he's
looking young again you're like what the
hell is going on and then on top of that
he's the bad guy the grey man has
definitely shown that chris evans can
play a villain as well so yeah fingers
crossed to do something like that as i
think that would absolutely that would
be incredible and lastly following on
from this to close out phase five is the
thunderbolts you know i don't think
anyone's going to win any prizes for
guessing that this was coming but
congratulations if you did and i'd
imagine that this is going to have the
characters that val's been recruiting
all coming together to sort of be the
mcu's version of the suicide squad oh
wait that's the illuminati
now big point of contention over the
entire event is where the hell is armor
wars you could say people are saying
where are my wars
and haha it's uh it's puns like that why
people don't watch the videos anymore
now with this being missing a lot of
people are speculating that it's been
cancelled or even moved to phase seven
but if you look at the phase five slate
there's actually several spots missing
on it marvel don't want to blow that
load at comic-con and they have d23
coming up in september so my guess is
that they're gonna flash out more of
phase six there and then some casting
for things like the x-men and the
fantastic four and yeah they just didn't
want to drop it all here mate back off
they've given you enough they've spoiled
you you ungrateful son of a [ __ ]
out of this entire thing depending on
what they do with captain america new
world order from what we got i think i'm
most excited for daredevil born again
one of my big complaints i've had about
the disney plus shows is that they don't
really have enough room to fully develop
everything because they've got a set of
characters in six episodes develop an
arc with the villain and also pay things
off with a finale it's a it's a lot to
pull off and to me they haven't exactly
done it the best way that they could
have because it's very very restrictive
having these six hour seasons 18
episodes is going beyond the length of
the netflix ones but i'm guessing that
they won't be an hour long however even
if they're 30 to 40 minutes that's still
quite a lot and it's gonna allow for
some real character development between
kingpin and daredevil now in case you
haven't read born again kingpin ends up
finding out daredevil's identity from
karen page and he starts to terrorize
his life matt murdock's home is
destroyed all his friends are turned
against him and his reputation is
completely ruined it's the lowest that
the character's ever been and by far one
of the best stories involving him it
also seems like his new costume is going
to be very similar to the original one
with flashes of yellow popping up
throughout it this could be seen in the
she-hulk teaser if you paused it at the
right time and yeah very excited to see
how this looks when it debuts in that
other minor update on this slate as well
is that agatha house of harkness has
been changed to agatha cover of chaos
chaos is a very important word there as
wander of course uses chaos magic and
though it might not tie into that agatha
was fascinated with her abilities so my
guess is that's why they've changed
things up now from here we jump over to
phase six and the first movie that we'll
be featuring in that is fantastic four
releasing november 8th 2024 this is
going to put a lot of things in place
for what's to come for the rest of the
phase now the next two titles were
announced and this is going to be
tell you 2025 gonna be a big year for
kevin spoilers and you you're some of a
[ __ ] starting off on may 2nd we'll be
getting avengers the kang dynasty the
kang dynasty sometimes gets called the
kang war and this 16 part comic book
storyline started way back in 2001.
interestingly marvel actually
re-released a version of it just off the
back of loki which i picked up and yeah
there's a lot of things to look forward
to in that one it basically involves
kang journeying to earth with his son
marcus and as you can guess he's trying
to conquer the planet
he actually accomplishes his goals and
just in the same way that infinity war
ended with thanos winning i'm guessing
that kang will win in this too this will
massively set up things for secret wars
which will then follow it and we'll sort
of have that being the multiverse sagas
end game with everyone you know probably
on the back foot trying to come back
secret wars is also a massive property
in the marvel universe as well and that
basically centers around a planet called
battle world which has pulled together
all the fractured timelines throughout
the multiverse we're going to be getting
lots of different versions of characters
and they're all going to be fighting for
control as they probably try to take
down kang i think it would be absolutely
incredible if we got the portal scene at
the end of avengers end game but this
time we had characters from every single
franchise i'm talking the amazing
spider-man i'm talking the x-men it's
all coming together like this would be
absolutely mind-blowing biggest movie of
all time after probably avatar 2 because
you know
jimmy cameron who always has a trick up
his sleeve so hell of a lot going on
there especially if you know what these
titles pull from and the graphic novels
that surround them which i am very
excited about i do kind of feel like
there is a lot of marvel at the moment
and that they could possibly
oversaturate themselves but there's some
massive titles on here that i'm very
hyped up to see i'm just hoping that the
quantity doesn't take away from the
quality as i do feel phase 4 has been a
bit hit and miss overall but there have
been some really great titles in there
i'm someone who absolutely loved
multiverse of madness no way home
chongqi actually quite liked eternals
but some of the rest of them you know
they've not exactly been amazing
must-see films so i'm hoping that
there's a high benchmark set across the
board here and with wakanda forever
coming in november i'm ready to just go
into that and then yeah see how things
all play out that will be the end of
phase four and then from there we'll be
diving into phase five which is a
massive leap for marvel they have the
chance to either knock it out the park
or they could let us down more than
henry cavill not showing up i'm i'm
still annoyed about it
but yeah now i want to turn things over
to you you've heard the titles some of
my brief thoughts on them and yeah what
do you think are you hyped are you
disappointed do you still care comment
below and let me know and just to let
you know we're giving away three copies
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august all you've
got to do to begin with the chance of
winning is just drop a comment made like
the video and make sure you subscribe
and we'll we might pick you
we might not but we might pick you now
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the black panther wakanda forever
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now very emotional filled with
easter eggs and hints towards the plot
so definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i'm gonna try
to go get some sleep you take care of
yourself peace